mark cuban's one of the most famous
investors in the world he built a
massive financial fortune during the
tech boom of the 90s into the early
2000s and is using many of the lessons
he learned almost 20 years ago to
understand what may happen next in
crypto mark's main lesson was that in
the late 90s there was this big big boom
anyone who put com on the end of their
company name they seem to only have
their stock prices go up and there's
lots of people who made money there's
also people who ended up getting left
holding the bag during 2000 when all of
a sudden it all came crashing down right
after the tech bust of 2000 and that
dot-com tragedy all of a sudden we had
this consolidation phase the bad
companies were washed out the good
companies gained market share those that
remained those that survived they ended
up building generation defining
companies now mark cuban he made an
absolute fortune during this time he
sold multiple companies over a couple of
years there and now he thinks the same
exact thing is going to happen here in
2022 he believes that crypto is
experiencing one of those busts and
there's going to be a consolidation
phase next and the projects that are
just copycats or the projects that
aren't actually going to survive they're
going to get washed out they'll go to
zero people will lose lots of money but
those that are able to thrive over time
and still be around once we get to the
other side of the consolidation phase
they've got a chance to be something
quite special and so of course history
isn't necessarily a guide to the future
but one thing that i do know is that
people have been around for quite a
while those that were investing during
the dot-com boom or those who navigated
the global financial crisis successfully
you might want to listen to some of the
stuff they have to say they're not
always going to be right but every once
in a while experience and an
understanding of history serves
investors well and this is probably one
of those times
as bad as you think it can get it can
always get worse as long as you think
the bad times can last it can always
last longer but every once in a while
the doomsayers sometimes they're wrong
sometimes they think it'll be way worse
than it actually is and sometimes they
think it'll last for two three four
years and it doesn't last that long
understanding what's happened in the
past through various market cycles is
important to being informed about what's
happening right now hearing mark cuban's
thoughts about a potential consolidation
phase a washout of the weaker companies
and projects and the strongest companies
surviving tends to make a lot of sense
to me it'll be fascinating to see how
accurate he is and to see what it plays
out in the market
stay alert out there keep your head on a
swivel make sure you study history and
understand that nobody has a crystal
ball about the future hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time